[Musique]
j'agis pour l'avenir de la planète
je suis l'ondé de choc nécessaire
je suis l'avenir de l'évolution humaine
à l'épreuve des balles
un surhomme vous êtes qui le met shore
la mission est compromise
qu'il nous faut un coup de main
[Musique]
notre cible s'appelle brixton
c'est un revenant on a besoin des
meilleurs chasseurs du métier luc holtz
je me décrirais comme le distributeur de
branlées clique de carrière l'a jamais
sa proie et on a besoin d'opérer en sous
main des cartes chaud je suis le mec qui
vous embrouille au chant ty ancien agent
des voiliers du mi6 fait cavalier seul
si on veut avoir une chance contre
brixton vous allez devoir travailler en
bio
com
que dalle ce gars c'était tout
pour ce boulot
pour savoir se faire tout petit
à
tu as vu ton look je vais sauver le
monde et pour ta gouverne
ce sera la quatrième fois
je suis fort à ce jeu là on n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'on raconte
obs et chaud
vous voulez la guerre
vous l'avez
vous vous souvenez mois
à troyes je suis un e
ouah
[Musique]
trois secousses et c'est la mort un
voyant plein fameuse tirade du méchant
faut que tu joues tu peux pas t'empêcher
je croyais que ça allait détendre
l'atmosphère